Jake:可以好
Jake: Okay, sure.
Shure: 行了这
Shure: Alright, that's it.
Katrina: music
Katrina: Music.
其他人：太简单了太简单了
Shure: 呜
Shure: 5678223456789323456784234567停
Shure: 5678223456789323456784234567 stop.
Shure: 洒洒水
Shure: Just a piece of cake.
Shure: 三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Three four five six seven eight two two three four five.
Shure: 六七八三二三四五
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four five.
Shure: 六七八四二三四跑
Shure: Six seven eight four two three four run.
Shure: yes OK
Shure: Yes, OK.
Shure: 二三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight two two three four five.
Shure: 六七八三二三四顶
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four push.
Shure: 二
Shure: Two.
Katrina: 二我已经拥有了
Katrina: Two, I already got it.
Lucia: 我们已经自动有了代教老师了
Lucia: We already have a substitute teacher automatically.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 一二三四
Shure: One two three four.
Shure: 是不是舞室就是都是这个样子
其他人：我们可以直接快进到那个一倍速
Katrina: 突然把屁股顶了出去
Katrina: Suddenly thrusting the butt out.
Shure: 1234
Shure: One two three four.
Shure: 56
Shure: Five six.
Shure: 5678
Shure: Five six seven eight.
Shure: 12345678
Shure: One two three four five six seven eight.